[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's going crazy
uh
good morning guys it's very early it's
around five o'clock we've been driving
since 4 30.
we're on the way to an area called
pleitenberg
bay also known as plate here in south
africa and the kid and i we're going
deep sea fishing
and it's important because we have a
competition today his husband
against wife we're going to see who's
going to catch
the most fish let's do it
[Music]
let me show you who's the guy that's
going to help us to go fishing
this is henrico's churches but uh
patrick is the guy he's going to help us
today
morning good morning are you good good
good good welcome you ready
yeah absolutely in south africa they
have a different style here so we're
going to take the boat in with a tractor
let's do it that's our tractor driver
right over there morning
[Music]
[Music]
okay and this is a competition today
i've got two of the same lures out there
two hulcos same colors left hand side of
the boat or let's say right hand side if
you take it from the front
to the heaters left-hand side of the
boat
is yours all right middle you're gonna
shake okay
one one one one one one for the middle
right yours
left yours uh
okay
come on buddy
going under the boat
okay so that's what you call it yeah
this is him right
nice whatever
they get yeah so it's one one
one
that go to the thick part of the red up
above this yeah that's all fish
oh
[Music]
[Music]
discrimination
yeah how big do they get these guys um
the
other ones people just now is probably
they
they thought the man is the biggest
okay so you're leading in front with the
most but i'm leaning in front with the
figures
but the competition is nothing but the
biggest right
who said what is it no no it was very
clear
[Music]
how did you see that yes i learned
something new
and you all forget you just put your
right it's on yeah
it was the same thing as that okay
yes
let's do it
just gotta
it's gonna come
there we go
[Music]
yes okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
no if you go to that side of the boat
yeah throw this loo and you want it
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
ah
now it's gonna be ladies in the lead
oh
what i think we're gonna do i think this
is gonna be the ipad we're gonna catch
so they fought 18 each now
that's also a problem then how do we
call it first one to
10 first one
so you're going to catch thing because
you can take some fish back and give to
everyone okay
then we're going to go for coffee okay
let's relax a little bit and take a
chill yeah yeah he doesn't even
begin to guard for the romans and we're
going to give the romans a good solid
try
yeah and then probably we're going to
need to go all right that's good
four
[Music]
oh
he follows him
as well right yeah makes it even better
that's my first first time ever
[Music]
donnie
[Music]
oh
yes
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
what
[Music]
i was like
sorry
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay so it's 6 6 9
[Applause]
oh
uh
[Music]
wow
yes
[Music]
here we go
seven nine seven yes husbands
we're on the win here
okay bye yeah i'll give you that
thank you well done not over
but just one more and i win
[Music]
because they stole romans 2
there we go
sorry i just want to hear who's the
winner you're the winner
well you did good
[Music]
hello
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right guys we're gonna go bottom
fishing but first we're catching
the bait so clinky is busy here jigging
and then he just caught one
there's beak in there quite a scary
thing it can bite
wow so yeah it's going very here big
ones departing yeah
there we go all right guys here we are
yeah
now that you can see on the gps and um
that's normally a good sign for for the
fish they're targeting now which is a
roman
all right um we're going to both fish
from the same side
okay so i'm going to pop when i see the
drift we can just drift down together
and not one deciding fishing under the
boat right there's two baits on you're
gonna hit the bottom
you're gonna take up the slack a little
bit we might get stuck on the bottom
once or twice but we're just gonna break
off in a new set okay okay
thank you so dan you guys can sit on
this side then i'll just dribble this
edge
all the time one right there one right
there
do you have a seat here and the thing is
there's going to be pekkas guys
lots of pekkas they're going to
distinguish between a pekka
and a roman okay
all about the field all about the ladies
okay down you go bombs away so i have to
feel until it drops boom
you hit the bottom you just take up a
bit of slack we're just gonna watch
we'll do like three or four drifts here
in a few months
okay shots and we're gonna go fishing
okay so we're gonna wait now
okay you gotta pick there was a there
was a yeah you gotta give it some more
slack
let's go right up there so he bites he
doesn't spit you out that when you feel
a better pull you just go down with it
go down with him and then you can strike
that's the reef yeah okay okay
so i do that just up here
that was a
so there's a big difference there's a
huge difference there we go
huh you'll feel when arriving picks you
up
you want to be up here but mostly you
can give him time because otherwise he's
just going to
fight and you're not going to be able to
give him enough he's going to feel
tension he's going to cough you
and a bigger roman is a skeleton it
doesn't just
bite for fun okay
let's see let's see
oh
nice thank you
we can only catch two of these two of
those okay only two
you're behind come on be patient with
that bait damn not every roman gives you
a
awesome bait like that back okay all
right okay nikita are you ready
yes there's one room and there should be
a couple more
okay
over the sand you don't feel any bites
when you get to the reef again in
advance
we're gonna fish straight up and down
now hit the bottom
don't stay there for too long just come
up
and junior ryman yeah i'm not a keeper
yeah but it's silly
it is
oh what the [ __ ]
how did you know
[Music]
what
and it's uh
there it is
[Music]
nice one brave
just eat the octopus like in china
that's him that's our winner
yes we're in trouble
no it's a red steel brush
you are my litman
that's gorgeous let's just take
talk but a quick bounce
all right guys we just arrived back here
at the beach standing
right next to the boat and who won the
competition
yeah the husbands won this one i was
fighting for all you guys all the
husbands and all the men out there
and today we won yeah just today until
next time
but uh let's finish this off nicely
let's go and eat the fish
we're gonna go to enrique's restaurant
here in pletenberg bay
so come and check it out let's go
[Music]
do
[Music]
you